Hello, Ah it works, great.
View is fantastic from up here
Oh, I'm up there
Before I begin, I want to give a shout out
to my mum.
She is a caretaker, and even though she doesn't
understand anything about computers, she watches
all my talks.
I think in particular she will like this one
about hand crafting web assembly.
So, yes, welcome, everyone.
We've heard a lot about JavaScript so far,
and now it's time talk about WebAssembly,
so hold on to your brains.
My name is Emil Bay.
I live in Copenhagen in Denmark, and I'm an
independent consultant primarily working with
crypto- mathematics, and drifted systems,
and, when I say "crypto-"I mean the real,
the cryptology, not the currencies, and all
that.
Yes, I used to study math but dropped out,
and all that, and now I work in software.
So, as I said, I was also here last year.
I looked a little bit different, got a shave
and a hair cut.
So, yes.
Okay.
So, WebAssembly.
Just want to get everyone on the same page.
So, we all understand what we are talking
about here today.
So WebAssembly, this is from the WebAssembly
website.
WebAssembly is a binary instruction format
for stack-based virtual machine.
It sounds very fancy, but we can forget about
that for today.
We're not going to use those big words.
So, it all looked like, there is a lot of
technical terms in here.
Instead, maybe we should do a bit about the
word "WebAssembly" "web" and "assembly", and
you might get connotation s in that it must
be a computer language before you can do something
with maybe a web browser, something, but actually,
WebAssembly is neither very web nor very assembly.
I don't know where this quote came from.
I think I read it online somewhere.
But it's not very web, because in WebAssembly,
you cannot actually do very much.
You don't have access to any web APIs unless
you give access, and it's also not very assembly
in the sense that it's not — WebAssembly
is not the code that's running on the machine
— it's very close to the machine — but
it is still an abstraction.
Just to clear everything out, I have another
couple of points about what WebAssembly isn't
before we get to look at some code.
First of all, from WebAssembly, you cannot
do sys calls which is a fancy word for saying
you cannot ... with the operating system unless
you give WebAssembly explicit access, and
explicit access has to go through JavaScript
as it is today.
From WebAssembly, you can only do the things
you can in JavaScript and only if you give
it explicit access.
It also does not give you any new hardware
access.
The reason I have this one on here is that
people — the whole story about WebAssembly
is that you can take your native programmes
and compile them in WebAssembly and run them
in a web browser.
That gives people the impression they can
take any native app, like a Bluetooth library,
put it into a exiled with M script, whatever,
into WebAssembly, and run it in the browser.
That's not how it, would.
You also don't get no new hardware access.
Actually will be you — actually, there's
no magic.
It's pure computational WebAssembly.
So that was a lot of negativity, so what is
WebAssembly?
Well, one thing I'm extremely excited about
in WebAssembly is that we have 64-bit integers,
and we heard about BigInt earlier today, and
64-bit in WebAssembly means that we can pinpoint
precision optimisation of the things that
have to do with computing with numbers.
I work with cryptography, and a lot of time,
we are dealing with numbers that are 256-bits
or 512-bits long, and 4-bit integers are a
real performance boost.
You get a performance boost by taking your
code and converting it to WebAssembly but
not as much as people would like to think
in my experience.
From most of the former benchmarks I've been
running, I see a performance boost of about
20 to 30 per cent over JavaScript, and that
is because JavaScript is very, very fast with
the new — the new engines like SpiderMonkey,
and all that.
You get surgical precision.
In JavaScript, when you write code, you often
don't know the exact performance profile of
what you're doing unless you have very deep
knowledge about what the VM is doing underneath.
With WebAssembly, you get much closer to what
it's going to be going on on your computer,
so you get a more predictable performance
profile.
And, one thing I'm excited about WebAssembly,
is that soon it may be the only language that
is truly run anywhere.
I'm seeing people do projects with writing
WebAssembly drivers for the Linux kernel,
and there are also people embedding WebAssembly,
and it's on the browser at load, and maybe
also come to embed it and WebAssembly is not
a technical any woo we can use in the future,
we can use WebAssembly today.
We can see globally, it has 73 per cent support
across the browsers, and it is also in Node
8.
So you can use this today.
That quote I had earlier from the WebAssembly
website, there was something more to it, because
WebAssembly is the sign to be a format that
you take your C++, or C programmes of Rust,
and now also Go programmes, and you can compile
into WebAssembly.
The only problem is that I didn't read that,
so, this is why today we're going talk about
the WebAssembly text format.
This is writing WebAssembly by hand, not taking
computer programme and compiling it down as
WebAssembly.
No, we get full control, and we know what
is going to happen inside the computer.
It's a very small programming language.
And it's one-to-one with the binary format
with a through caveats, but you know exactly
the programme you wrote, what it's going to
be compiled into.
There's no optimisation in between, and no
moving things around, or anything like that.
You know exactly what is going to go on.
It has an appropriate acronym — "WHAT" — which
is what you'll be saying most of the time
when you look at the WebAssembly programmes.
I want to make clear that the programming
language we look at next is an official language
from the WebAssembly working group.
It is not something I invented or [unclear]
someone else wrote.
It is official language.
So, that's enough talking.
Let's look at some code.
Here we have our first WebAssembly module.
This is the "hello, world" of WebAssembly.
If you squint a bit, you can see what this
module does.
So that everyone gets it, I'm also for my
own sake, going to walk through some highlights.
The function calls look beard because they
are S expressions, and some people who may
have been programming in Clojure will find
this familiar.
It is a little bit foreign is to to JavaScript
developers but you get used to it very quickly.
It is like having a list before the function
name or after.
There's not much more to it.
Next thing we notice is that we have to wrap
everything in a module, and that's like an
ES6 module.
You can have one module per file as it is
right now.
That's just a boilerplate.
Next we can see we have these dollar signs,
and you might think that is going to be the
variables.
Not exactly.
It is more like a human-friendly name to be
able to access the — you can see here, I
gave the function name call square with a
dollar sign in front, but as soon as you compile
the programme, all of these texts are going
to disappear and be replaced with a number
so the binary is going to be very small.
Next thing you know is that that explicit
typing everywhere, and this is part of the
security module, so that the WebAssembly virtual
machine can look at the binary and make sure
that it is going to be guaranteed to be well
behaved, that it doesn't access memory it's
not supposed to, and the functions have matching
types and you don't have undefined behaviour.
Also in the the third highlight there.
That's not actually a type but an operator.
They follow the convention that the first
part of the name is the return type, and then,
after the dot, you have whatever you're doing.
Here, we are doing I32 ultimate multiplication,
which is an integer that is 32 bits wide.
Those are the integers you can operate on
in JavaScript, if you do — your number's
going to be cast to a 32-bit integer.
The last thing that makes it verbose is that
you have to make all access explicit, so here
we get a local variable, a variable from the
local scope where we are getting the parameter,
the input, and you can think of this goes
and gets the values and replaces whatever
is in the text, and that's a way for you to
evaluate what expressions in your head is
you can start from the — all the way from
the inside, and then you can replace the things
as you go outside and try and evaluate it
in your head.
So, also, the explicit access is something
you will probably want to optimise in hard
code, so that is why it is also very nice
that the accesses are very explicit, and you
know exactly what is happening.
So, we have our first module.
The next thing is we need to be able to run
this, so we need a compiler.
The compiler that I'm using comes from the
What project but my friend Mateus put it on
MPM so it is easy to install.
You run the web binary tool kit, it will fetch
the latest version of the compiler and exile
it for you — compile it for you.
Let's look at the demo.
Because, now, we have — can I — oh, I
have to do it like this.
Where's my ... . A terminal here.
I have a square function here, so this looks
a little bit different because this is the
way that I planned it, the parentheses, messed
up, because I have a tool in my editor to
help me out writing What code.
We will use the What-to-Wasm compiler.
Now we have the square dot WASM.
This is a binary file so I will use hex dump
with the C option, and ... this is what the
binary module looks like.
You can see the function name because we exported
it, so it needs to keep the string, and then,
if you're familiar with WebAssembly, you can
see the up codes up there, so you can see
the access to the variables and the multiplications,
and all that.
I'm no brain man, so I can't read this.
Where did my cursor go?
Damn it!
How do I escape?
There we go.
Okay.
Now, the next thing is we have the binary
module, then we need to import it, and actually
use it.
So, this is the boilerplate from the JavaScript
side that you use to read out the WebAssembly
module.
Now, this looks very complicated to me.
I have a very weird definition of what is
complicated, so this is also packaged up in
a tool that you can use from MPM.
You can install What to JS which takes your
What module, compiles it down to Wasm and
wraps it in a JavaScript function or module
so you can import that directly instead of
having to go and fetch the WebAssembly module
and do the instantiation, and all that.
So the way you do that is you would call what.js
with your WebAssembly file and output a JavaScript
file.
Let's have a look at that.
I have it installed.
I'm going to take the squared of What.
Put it in square dot.
Then we have the — you can see I have the
example file here.
It just imports the WASM module, and then
the exporter function square with two, and
then we should see four will be right?
I'm going to run the example Node.
Got four.
Now we have a running WASM programme — very
cool.
[Applause].
Thank you.
Okay.
Here is the code for reference.
Next step, now we have the basically flowdown,
now we will look at a real What programme,
and also a programme structured like I write
what What.
The function we look at is a function to compute
the distance between points.
It might seem contrived but this could be
a call function if you're building a physics
library, or maybe doing some machine-learning,
or some other AI.
Distances are very important.
You can see we have a lot of new syntax here,
so I'm just going to walk you through it.
The thing I said before about the brackets
is that I have this plugin that is pretty
much all the most common editor is called
... that helps you set the brackets, so instead
of me having to type out the brackets manually,
it decides where the brackets are supposed
to be put, based on indentation.
That's what you also know from Python, indentation
is what decides how things are scoped.
Here is the tour of this module.
You can see up in the top I give it a name.
F64, and that's like the Wasm convention.
That's how I like to name my functions so
I know what the return type is.
You can see the return type is F64.
F64 means double floating point.
That is exactly what numbers on JavaScript,
so this is exactly like a number in JavaScript
where you have decimal places.
Then you can see I defined some local variables.
These local variables have to be all the way
at the top of the function.
That's just how Wasm is so something to do
with how to allocate the registers that are
required for this.
You can also see at the bottom we use a new
function, the F64 square root, and then we
have a call here.
And the call is to the call is to the square
function because this is a formula for the
distance between two points.
The call here is important.
If you import a JavaScript function into a
WebAssembly module, then you would also invoke
that function with the call — yes.
There is a problem, though.
If we try and compile this, we get a mismatch,
and that's because, unlike in JavaScript,
you have to explicitly convert everything
so, in this case, our I32 add goes back to
I32 because it says so, so we have to convert
that.
So we add a new instruction, and this can
lead to some verbosity, but I think this verbosity
is important because it does cost to convert
between things so you want to keep your types
stable.
In this place here, the convert_u means that
it doesn't have a sign, that it is a positive
number.
So, that was the distance function.
I'm going to show here, this is what it looks
like when you call it, so the dot, I don't
want to give the wrong impression, this dot
here we saw before, in the statement, it doesn't
mean that you put the distance on an object.
It is the name of the property.
So we have to invoke it like this.
So, are we having fun yet?
I said this was going to be fun.
So, but let's take it up a notch.
Now we're going to look at a more practical
function, something you would go and use at
home.
We are going to do distance between vectors,
and it sounds very fancy.
It means that we want to take the distance
between two arrays.
Why would you do that?
For example, you can take an image from a
canvas element, and some tracking from each
other, and that way, you can find a difference,
and that's how most of the new visual tools
that work take two villages" subtract foreign
minister them from each other, and you get
the artefacts of the difference.
You can see there is a lot of stuff going
on here.
This is also a real-world example because
now we're actually getting to deal with memory.
Memory is one of the big concepts that we
never really talked too much about in JavaScript,
because it's all handled for us.
But, in WebAssembly, you have to be extremely
explicit, allocate the memory itself, you
have to manage it yourself, and you only get
one piece.
But memory is not too hard to think about.
It's just like a very big array.
Where you can put numbers into.
So, as you can see, we have a memory definition,
and I export the memory, so I have access
to it from JavaScript.
You can choose not to export it if it is part
of your security model, and you have the 1,
which means I want one page of memory, and
a page of memory is 65 kilobytes.
When you want more memory, you increment in
pages.
You can also see the parameters here.
I've given them funny Michelle Dewberry and
Andy Walton.
If you've done anything with C, you will know
about pointers, because now that we have one
big piece of memory, we need to have pointers
into that memory, and pointer is just a fancy
word for index, so you know the I in the foreloop.
And since we're using pointers, the array
doesn't have an inherent length, so we in
these to parts in the length — parse in
the length explicitly.
This is how numbers look when they are put
into memory.
At the topping you can see I have this i8
for an 8-bit integer, also called a byte,
so a byte array.
Next we will take examples from the typescript
we've seen before.
For example, i42 takes — that is something
to be aware about when you need to allocate
memory.
The way we are going to parse in our arrays
is using the pointer and the link, and this
is what it is going to look like in the linear
memory.
We have a pointer which is an index into the
memory, so, just a number, and then we have
the length for how far we have used the memory.
You might also notice that these pointers
are i32s, but before I said I was excited
about i64s because all addressing in Wembley
is 32-bit, and — WebAssembly is 32 bit.
When I got my first computer, it was one of
the first 64-bit computers because I could
have eight gigabytes of memory.
This is only 32 bits which only means your
module can only use four gigabytes of memory.
It might change in the future, but for the
— you only have four gigabytes at your disposal.
To put in data into the memory, I have written
this little script here.
We are going with the idea of diffing two
images.
First, we need to make sure that we have enough
memory available otherwise we're going to
go out of bounds.
At the beginning, I allocate how long the
two images are, make sure we have that memory
available.
Then I remember a point er to where I'm going
to put the first image like we had in this
graphic.
And then I set the image.
You can just set it directly if you copy,
type it in, and I increment the offset because
we put the first array in the beginning.
After that, we put the second array, and you
can see in the end here, I then call the function
with the arguments we just saw.
In this case, this is going to give back a
single number, but if, if I wanted, for example,
return the difference between the two images,
I could also pass back a pointer which is
going to be a number, so that number I could
use to go into the WASM memory and read out
what the difference image is.
One way to get image data, for example, with
a canvas is like this.
Here, we get the image data.
You have loaded the image in our own, and
you can find that — and the image data has
a data property which is a array with RGBA
in each of the cells.
So that is an easy way to get started with
this example.
The next code is when you need to access the
memory from inside WebAssembly, you need to
be explicit about loading out things from
memory, because loading from memory can also
be very expensive.
You can also see here that, because the pointer
is a number, when I want to go to the next
element, I need to add two numbers together.
So here we load two bites, and you can see
— bytes, you can see the underscore you.
Unsigned is — as you see, data array, that
is just because of the way — of the data
I was loading.
Lasting we need here is that we want to iterate
the whole array, so, the way we do that is
with something called of course a loop, but
a loop in WebAssembly is a little bit different
than the loops you know from JavaScript, because
in WebAssembly, it's about branching.
In JavaScript, we have branching we have continue
and break which are two ways to branch inside
a foreloop or a wild loop, or whatever.
In this case, you can look at a loop as a
do-while.
We look at the loop and execute our code.
At the end, we have a conditional branch,
so that means we are going to go to back,
we're going to go back to the label, continue
if our condition over here is true, so in
this case, I'm incrementing the offset, and
checking the offset — reading out of bounds
is one of those notorious errors or security
bugs that you get all the time in C programmes,
and you will get that in WebAssembly if you're
not careful.
That was the business function, and this is
I think a real world example.
I've used this to present a machine-learning
algorithm which you can use to find primary
calls and images, and that kind of stuff,
and I want to reiterate that this is not just
for fun.
I mean, we had fun, right?
It's not just for fun.
There is serious code out there, so I'm part
of a GitHub organisation called Sodium Friends.
This is where we have a project called, with
— we have bindings to Lip Sodium which is
a crypto-library written in C. What if you
want to provide cryptography to your users
in the browser?.then you can go and install
Sodium Universal which has five or ten algorithms
now handwritten in WebAssembly.
It has taken about a day to hand write each
algorithm.
They are about a couple of thousand lines
of code, but this is actual in production
now, Sodium Universal has 2,000 downloads
a week, and it has even more downloads from
official channels, built into the bigger browser,
and those don't show up in the statistics.
I see I have four minutes left.
I have something very exciting I want to show
you.
This thing about writing WebAssembly, it can
quickly become repetitive.
This is real-world code from the Lip Sodium
project.
This is from a function called es cha-cha,
it is really dense code, awkward to read,
repetitive.
It would be easier if you could define a function,
call it, and then maybe search and replace,
and you can do that.
It's called macro-s in C. It's not build into
— it's not built into WebAssembly.
It's easy to parse.
I built my pre-parser for web assemblies.
You can define macros which are like search
and replace.
Suddenly, the big function that is hard to
read becomes a lot more manageable.
I'm not sure what I want to call this project
yet.
It's not public.
I was thinking something like What Up, something
to that extent.
If you have good ideas, let me know on Twitter.
This was a little sneak peek of the future.
That's all I have to say.
Thank you!
[Applause]